upskilling not only helped to develop my
skills in Supply Chain management but
also helped me grab various other new
projects in the operations domain even
it got me a 20 percentage hike in my
salary
being a chartered accountant I was great
with numbers and handling Finance but
the knowledge of how a business operates
is what I lacked so I decided to turn my
weaknesses into strength and with simple
learn I was able to achieve it with
flying colors
I live in coimbatore I work as an
account specialist at helenbrand
Industries in 2022 I completed my
professional degree in CA and became an
ICA certified chartered accountant I
work for various consultancy firms and
handle their finances but then I
realized to grow higher in my career I
needed to strengthen my operational
strategies so I decided to acquire these
desired skills and operation management
I came across simple learns digital
Supply Chain management in collaboration
with Purdue University and that's where
my journey started upskilling not only
helped to develop my skills in Supply
Chain management but also helped me grab
various other new projects in the
operations domain even it got me a 20
percentage hike in my salary the course
helped me gain new skills in how a
business should be carried out simple
learns course has all the relevant
required industry course material that
prepares you for the functions in the
correct Market the projects segments
after every module strengthen my
Concepts and today I may can easily
execute those skills in my career with
the growing demands in operations and
Supply Chain management this course
helped me to upgrade myself for greater
career opportunities that wouldn't have
come my way if I didn't upskill myself
apart from work I love to cook whenever
I get time
it has become my passion in the coming
years I would like to grow
professionally and one day become a CEO
or CEO of a Fortune 500 company and with
the decision to upskill I feel that I
have taken the right step forward it's
not the mountains that we conquer but
ourselves so obscale yourself and
conquer all the mountains that are
stopping your career from moving ahead
[Music]